hi there steve here again and today
i want to talk a little bit about online
language learning
because this has been how this is the
sort of world in which i have been
learning languages over the last 10 12
years it's very different from when i
learned languages 50 years ago
it has so many advantages
and i think some people are not fully
aware of these so i'm going to go
through some of them
i think the big thing with online
language learning first of all it
doesn't necessarily replace
books i buy lots of books i have all
kinds of language books
it doesn't necessarily replace the
classroom
uh you can certainly
enjoy going to a class and still take
advantage of online language learning
online language learning doesn't
necessarily mean
getting a tutor online although that is
one of the many things you can do
if you learn in an online environment
the biggest thing about online language
learning is that it puts you the learner
in control
if you go to a classroom you're more or
less
dependent on
the teacher leading you through
whatever it is the teacher wants to
teach you
we're gonna do chapter one we're gonna
do chapter two we're gonna study verbs
today we're gonna do numbers today
whatever it is the teacher is in charge
uh with online language learning you
seek out what you want
all right
now
uh
it's important to remember
as stephen krashen says that language
learning consists
of our language acquisition is based on
basically accessing meaningful
content meaningful communication the
more meaningful
reading and listening you do
to
messages of interest content of interest
the sooner you are going to
acquire the language
at some point you'll also start speaking
so
therefore the principal advantage of
online language learning is that you can
find so much content online both audio
and text
you can
you know google and i should say that
one of the biggest tools one of the best
friends of online language learners is
google you can google for grammar
resources you can google for
reading content listening content audio
books radio programs podcast whatever
you can think of you can google in your
own language or you can translate it
again using google translate and then
you can google in your target language
in order to find the resources that
you're looking for
google therefore helps you find content
you can google for any grammar question
you have and you'll find hundreds of
pages if you want to google for
japanese verbs or romanian nouns or
youth i don't know i've never tried but
vietnamese
grammar or whatever you want you google
you'll find it you'll find explanations
you'll find pdf files you'll find all
kinds of things that you might be
looking for and so
once you have the initiative then if you
have an issue in a language
where you're uncertain about how do
the verbs work in this language you can
google for it and get it now get the
explanation you don't need to wait to
ask the teacher in the classroom
google also has text to speech
uh google is just an amazing tool
mind you there's other text to speech as
well
another thing about online language
learning is you can find
an online tutor
and more and more teachers are hanging
up their shingles so to speak to offer
language instruction online but as an
online learner you can choose how often
you want to go and you can have these
one-on-one
or in groups
and you know as an example
i have had now four or five sessions in
arabic where i speak in arabic
uh with a very nice guy
uh in arabic you know and now i've
decided i'm gonna take a rest
because it's a bit stressful
i would rather
i've decided
continue
to
ingest the language become more and more
familiar with the vocabulary and how it
works
before i go back then to doing more
uh speaking online but it's my choice
it's my choice
and
you know since we need to read and
listen a lot you know the online
language learning world
includes of course online dictionaries
and
of course uh
mobile uh apple mobile uh devices so
when i say online language learning i
don't mean that we need to sit in front
of the computer
i do most of my uh reading and listening
using my iphone and ipad
and
so i am now
i know
that is a if i just continue reading in
arabic that i will just get better and
better at it the more i read the better
i get at it when i first started with
arabic i was using our sentence view in
our app doing one sentence at a time and
the translation was there and i was
fighting my way through it now i'm going
in sort of a page view
so i'm able to read now pages at a time
and eventually i'll go to the whole text
view so that i'm training myself to read
more and more and so i decided that i
would rather go back to focusing on
reading and acquiring vocabulary and
developing familiarity with the language
before i speak again with my tutor but
it's my choice i ha i'm in charge i can
look up arabic verbs i can arrange
you know a lesson via italki for example
or i can do it on link but i don't think
we have any arabic tutors there
i i'm in charge
so so it's a wonderful world i can have
online language learning as a supplement
to my class learning
uh i can
again i think books for example i bought
the lc mill book i bought this arab
model
but i also imported them
into links so that i could take
advantage of the online dictionaries and
the other functionality that we have so
online language learning is it lends
itself to any kind of blended learning
blended with a classroom experience
blended with a traditional
you know language book experience
or eventually as i've done in other
languages seeking out you know authentic
podcasts political podcasts audiobooks
e-books all of which
can be found on the web i found my
resources for czech for romanian for
greek for russian for ukrainian all of
these things i found them online
so
you know it's an amazing world the world
of online language learning we can do
with it what we want
uh the more we get into it the work the
more we search for content of interest
to us the more we search for grammar
resources that we need the more we
search for language partners
um
or for that matter follow people on
twitter
like kirsten or
ollie richards or whoever other people
that we come across who are interested
in languages urho languist there's a
whole bunch that i follow i can't
remember them all right away so this is
further sort of uh encouragement and and
uh
you know a sense of you're not alone so
this is another thing of course about
online language learning is that you can
connect with these communities of people
who either speak the language you're
learning or learning the language you're
learning or who are just keen on
languages so
online language learning is this modern
paradigm which i think has dramatically
improved the opportunities for people to
learn languages and i really encourage
people to take advantage of all the
opportunities that are there and to
share what they are doing with other
people via twitter for example so they
can stimulate other people to take
advantage or to find
resources
online that are going to help them learn
languages there you have it online
language learning from my perspective
bye for now
[Music]
you